uh let's talk to someone who can help us
with how these numbers are affecting
um the industry this is Mark Tate Mark
has been working here for a very long
time we're surrounded by food from all
over the world here getting it here and
you getting into customers comes at a
cost what's been happening to prices
this year and what have you seen just
recently we've had a very very hard year
produce has been very very short and
very very expensive and to Source the
products has been a major problem I
thought we've managed to carry on the
last week 10 days we've seen a little
bit more availability about in produce
and prices now are just starting to fall
on the right side so you know for the
customers so everybody else he's healthy
and eat well that's really interesting
so on the ground here just in the last
few days you're seeing real world
impacts that mirror that that fall off
inflation just give us an idea of some
of the price increase we've got
clementines over there there's a some we
buy a lot of at Christmas give us an
idea what's happened to the price
clementines were around about 10 pound a
box this time of year we've been 18
pounder box which is a colossal rise
there now it sees back it's about 15 16
pound a box which just starts to ease
back a little bit more produce coming
through the doors as well now as the gas
and oil prices are dropping so they can
put heat into the produce to bring the
produce on and onto our shelves it gives
our eggs is another one we've talked a
great deal avian foods but I just just
give you the numbers on on a box of eggs
a box of eggs was 32 pound uh probably
four months ago we're now 70 pound a box
colossal rise those kind of increases
on on common produce that people enjoy
consider routine products um you've got
no choice yeah that I mean we try to
absorb as much of the cost as we can
it's 365 days in a year we need to serve
our customers all year round and year on
year so we try and absorb as much as we
can but we can't absorb it all and that
has to be passed on to the end user you
mentioned part of the reason things have
started to dip Off fuel prices and
energy costs that's why energy is
important in food production oh in food
production with the greenhouses uh Spain
and Holland when they're hosting the
green houses through gas obviously they
get to a point and they think well we
can't turn the gas on to mature the
fruit to bring across because the prices
and what we can't get the price of the
product at this end so they just don't
bother bring these across in Korea it's
a shortage on the market as the gas
prices have started to drop and turn the
greenhouse on there bringing the fruit
forward a little bit more and it makes
it easier for everybody else this is the
time of year when everyone's thinking
about treating themselves food and drink
huge part of the Christmas experience
variance have you got any sense of what
the trading like you're coming into the
the key Fortnight I'm guessing for that
buying yes it is we start knowing our
shop we've got China fruit shops as well
I noticed considerably difference in the
last two or three days people are
starting to spend a few pounds in their
Christmas trees and reads a song very
very well the prices now are easing back
blueberries raspberries things like that
make them very very affordable for the
public to buy in the shops now easily
back so everybody has a happy fruitful
Christmas that's good news uh thank you
well give me that pictures